wer bei shanghai
jeder tag ist
wer weiß schon heute wo wir morgen sind
wir mal wieder alles neu beginnt so drei
leute wir sind heute in einem ganz
besonderen ort und zwar in einer klavier
werkstatt wo unser was die unser
keyboarder und pianist arbeitet als
klavierbauer wir werden klären gebaut
gar nicht geschraubt und repariert und
ich bin gespannt was passte dazu
erzählen hat weil das finde ich auch
totales neuland ist
jacobi gar nicht schlecht für den anfang
machen du bist einfach und erklären bist
du drin uns dieser sound überhaupt so
schön davon school komm mit ich zeig dir
ich hab dir schon mal hier ein klavier
zerlegt also das prinzip ist total
simpel die taste wird nach unten bewegt
die bewegen sich einige teile mit und
dadurch wie der hummer an die seite
geschleudert
und am flügel wird von unten die seite
angeschlagen
sag mal sacken
man kann nicht nur musik mit dem
filmischen spielekiste nicht stimmt ja
die seiten dann verändert
die bringe ich den ton ja also meine
gitarre sind 45 seiten einem klavier
über 200 seiten gibt drehen musst du
musst dich mit metall auskennen du musst
dich mit pils auskennen muss ich
natürlich mit holz auskennen mit
grundstoffen weil die tasten die sind
aus kunststoff bunten ist holz und oben
ist kunststoff ist sehr vielseitig und
musikalisch natürlich das sollte man
auch sein dass das jetzt bestimmt das
ist nicht nur ein modell das ist eine
oktave die ich gebaut habe
die hast du gebaut die habe ich gebaut
ist hast du alles hier gebaut das habe
ich alles selber gebaut und geschlecht
das ist meine gesellenprüfung wieso
gesellenprüfung bist du wissen ich bin
gesellig ich hab die ausbildung macht
und bin jetzt geselle
wenn man sich weiterentwickeln will oder
weiter lernen will dann kann man auch
den meister machen also dann bist du
klavierbaumeister und cembalo baumeister
bis zum nächsten mal